I have several elements of a personal
philosophy one is respect others respect
the views of others don't be dismissive
if people disagree with you don't simply
dismiss their arguments listen to their
arguments you may in the end not agree
with them but respect people's ability
to have different points of view which
in some cases can be just as valid as as
your own the second is integrity if you
can't exhibit integrity and the way you
deal with other people then you're
really not much of a person yourself and
ultimately people will see it third
avoid a big ego if one of the most
crushing burdens people have I found is
if they have a big ego because it it
causes them not to pay much attention to
others if they think that everything
they do everything they think is correct
you're not going to be a good listener
you're not going to be willing to take
criticism you're simply going to be so
dogged that you you first of all you
alien other people second you're
deprived of the benefit of hearing other
views that could be very valid in and
might well be much more valid than your
own and and the other is to see what you
do in terms of working with other people
the if you're if you're willing to share
credit for success you're going to get a
lot more people who are going to be on
your team whereas if you insist on
dominating them and you insist on taking
credit for everything good that happens
in blaming everything bad on someone
else you're not going to get much done
in life you have to include others and
make others feel that they're part of
your team knock knock by guys or by
sleight of hand but by really creating a
sense of tea
work and by hearing them out by ensuring
that their views can making them feel
that they're part of the of the process
because they have to be part of the
process all the problems we face today
are so significant that one person or
even a small group of people are not
going to resolve them you're not going
to change anything in Washington with
one or two people deciding that they
know best and no one else knows anything
you have to really engage them and the
same is true in a company you have to
really engage other people and listen to
them pay attention to them engaged in
the process and share credit if you
don't do that your your your ability to
succeed is very limited
hey